so there's this Tick Tock account called
move to North Korea and it basically is
like a propaganda account but it's in
this weird Lo-Fi way where they go
through and say like the North Korea you
think you know is a lie and actually
it's this very luxurious place with
mosques and movies and concerts and all
in all the casinos and all these things
and it just gets me thinking about truth
and how we're in a world where
everything is possible to make look
different than it is part of me has to
believe that this is like brilliant
political satire to make a point about
misinformation on the internet but I
kind of don't think it is I think we
actually live in this world where North
Korea the place the place that we know
is a desolate horrible place to live can
be framed like this on Tick Tock and
it's got to be convincing someone Wild